chaque pièce découverte avec une tête
donc sa série culte banques auxquelles
tête tabulaire la joie j'avais le joueur
a bien sûr j'avais la joie
[Musique]
je sais pas ce qu'il ya dans ce truc
mais croyez moi c'est vraiment hyper bon
c'est un espèce de mélange de cocktail
de bananes très frais je me suis dit
puisque on est parti avec 1000
dominicaine on pourrait se tester un
outil qui nous servirait par exemple
pour comprendre dans un pays où on va et
où on comprend absolument rien encore
ici ça vaille par l'espagnol tout est
traduit en anglais on comprend
relativement bien mais si vous partez en
asie c'est une galère absolue
du coup je vous présente un outil qui
est franchement hyper cool c'est ça la
leur mais avec moi j'ai prévu le coup
c'est iris peine r7 ça ressemble un peu
un test de grossesse
je laisse ça ça ressemble franchement un
test de grossesse
ça ressemble un fin tu trouves ça ouais
ouais c'est parce que tu sais pas ce que
c'est qu'un test de grossesse ça c'est
vrai ça sent franchement un test de
grossesse jésus tu es d'accord
grâce à ça vous allez pouvoir numériser
les textes que vous voulez donc ça
franchement c'est hyper cool et ça vous
le mets dans votre mac votre pc
smartphones android ios donc ça c'est
franchement hyper cool et ça permet
également de traduire smart aux als
penske alors l'idée c'est que ça n'a
vraiment venir scanner vos documents ça
se calme votre texte pouvait les éditer
sur n'importe quelle bécane ça je vous
le disais sur smartphone survie attend
ça c'est franchement cool et sous permet
de le traduire
et en plus ça vous le lien ça se
connecte en bluetooth sur le principe
c'est cool c'est à dans une poche c'est
très pratique vous avez ici la partie
qui sert à scanner suffit d'appuyer vous
montrez là vous voyez c'est lou s'est
connecté la batterie et à vous avez un
peu la partie à de recharge en micro usb
pour faire le test
le mieux c'est encore de prendre des
documents à traduire
donc j'ai une application dédiée en
fonction de chaque outil parce qu'on en
a plein fin voilà je vous montre celui
là donc là j'ai un document sans titre
que j'ai créée celle là on à madame
monsieur traitement en cours très à
numériser voyez madani monsieur et le
texte c'est madame monsieur alors on va
se faire une phrase un peu isolés ici
nous vous remercions de votre
compréhension nouveau
remercions de votre compréhension un paf
nous avec un espace vous remercions de
votre compréhension donc c'est pas mal
mais des fois ça a du mal un petit peu
alors est ce que c'est moi qui vais
peut-être pas à la bonne vitesse
je vais recommencer le sien d'aller plus
vite je vais mettre à la ligne en bas
hop je vais essayer de garder vraiment
la même vitesse c'est pas toujours
évident parce que ça allait beaucoup
trop vite près numérisés et là ça marche
nickel
nous vous remercions de votre
compréhension on va recommencer sur
madame monsieur et sa mamie un espace
encore avec madame monsieur ça marche
bien mais des fois il ya ces quelques
petits bugs alors après franchement
c'est hyper cool parce que lorsque vous
les numériser des textes un peu plus
long madame monsieur nous vous
remercions de votre achat et la
confiance que vous témoignez eiris
franchement le résultat est pas mal du
tout mais c'est vrai que des fois on a
l'impression qu'ils galèrent avec un
caractère donc ça on se l'est fait en
français maintenant va se faire dans une
autre langue en espagnol voilà je parle
très très mal espagnol une producto des
iris il perd la confiance a déposé un
nouveau score et là franchement le texte
est très très très très très juste
et ça pour le coup c'est hyper cool
alors maintenant on va se le fait rire
en mode traduction par exemple on va se
numériser une langue que je ne parle pas
c'est le turc tu parle turc toile iott
moi non plus on va dans l'application
je me crée un nouveau document je
sélectionne dans les paramètres ma
langue source gmi turkish maintenant je
vais numérisés en turc et on va voir ce
que ça dit
personnellement je ne parle pas un mot
turc
donc je vous cache pas que j'ai comprend
absolument rien par contre ce qui est
cool ensuite c'est que je vais dans ma
traduction traduction cours turkish
french merci pour la confiance que vous
avez reçu vous soyez et l'âge et la
traduction en français alors il se peut
que quelques petites coquilles
effectivement la numérisation mais
franchement c'est hyper hyper hyper
hyper cool chaque pièce découverte avec
une tête lensoise eric walter
en fait je l'avais reçu t'avais caltech
commence avec elton à coquelles tête
tavella la joie avoir de la joie bien
sûr j'avais la joie j'avais carrément la
joie totale et qu'elle coûte avec elle à
quelques aides toi quand tu l'as vu
qu'ils soient tellement aussi nous est
trop mignon
[Musique]
au final c'est tout il est franchement
couleur il destine à qui pourront ils
estiment à deux types de personnes elle
toute première personne c'est quand vous
travaillez dans un bureau et vous voulez
pas vous embêter à numériser que vous
voulez juste numériser une petite partie
même si vous allez texte un peu long à
numériser
c'est franchement pas mal c'est pas
idéal par contre ça reconnaît bien vous
numérisés vous éditez vous pouvez
corriger les petites coquilles lui
n'aura pas réussi à reconnaître ça va
bien c'est rapide c'est pratique et ça
c'est franchement cool donc ça c'est le
premier outil à usage professionnel ça
vous fera gagner du temps c'est cool
c'est pratique et ça dans différentes
langues ont franchement c'est hyper cool
le deuxième type de personne que je vois
là dessus c'est typiquement les
personnes qui voyagent beaucoup qui ont
dans des pays dont ils parlent pas
forcément la langue vous allez au
restaurant par exemple vous voulez
choisir un menu vous numériser le plaça
vous disent que c'est vous pouvez le
manger sans crainte c'est cool c'est une
bonne solution et même pour des
allergènes pour pas mal de choses ça
peut vous sauver la ville donc ce truc
là qui ressemble franchement à un test
de grossesse c'est hyper cool pour
travailler pour voyager moi en tout cas
je l'adoptent
je vais glisser dans mon sac avec mon
application sur mon smartphone je peux
aller partout je connaîtrai tous les
produits tous les plats plein de trucs
je trouve ça franchement hyper cool tu
en penses quoi toi il ya tout eu trop
bien ou pas ouais tu pourrais l'avoir
aussi wells il ya dix à cinq ans croyez
moi franchement c'est un truc est super
cool
m
[Musique]
pendant
oh là là ça va alors je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez vous d'une solution comme
ça est ce que ça peut vous tentez que ce
soit pour le bureau ou pour vos voyages
mark et moi tous ordres en commentaire
moi sur le principe tout ça cool je vous
dis ça serait bon d'améliorer encore un
petit peu la reconnaissance des tec ça
dépend aussi de la lumière ça dépend pas
mal de choses pour l'heure nous continue
nos vacances à bien magna très bien on
vous tue nos vacances nous à puerto
plata au rang des sites quelques jours
en france voilà en passant par toronto
pour l'instant on va se voir un petit
jus et cet aprem direction puerto plata
promis pour la ville je pense que ça va
être cool je contemple pour marquer tout
ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires
et puis on reste connectés voilà les
jeux vidéo
[Musique]